bonjour michael je suis sénateur
bienvenue qui responsable de la bérézina
de villeneuve sur lot françois hollande
où vous
à mort à l'incompréhensible inexcusable
dit le patron du groupe socialiste à
l'assemblée vous concernant alors qui
est responsable
hollande où vous en a beaucoup des
responsables je crois la situation du
pays bien évidemment dont
est particulièrement victimes le
candidat du gouvernement en place ce qui
est bien légitime c'est le candidat du
parti majoritaire
ce qui est aussi en cause dans cette
situation c'est le fait que l'ump
progressent peu je crois que
l'animation qu'ils ont misé dans le
débat démocratique hors division
l'absence de propositions fait que le
candidat avait donc j'ai dit et la
presse grâce à la politique de françois
hollande oui bien sûr l'essentiel vous
savez dans ces partielles on voit bien
c'est la huitième partiel que le parti
socialiste perd c'est donc évidemment de
la faute d'appétit du gouvernement et
donc le candidat socialiste on est
victimes ses sympathisants c'est de
votre faute qui met en avant le spectre
de 2002 les affaires j'ai
connu pour être un peu rationnelle et
analytique et donc ce qui me désole dans
cette histoire c'est que monsieur leroux
et une telle perte de lucidité c'est ça
qui est facho ces bisbilles très
sincèrement moi ça ça me glisse sur les
épaules comme il ya beaucoup d'eau c'est
assez facile à gérer mais la réalité
c'est comme être capable de pondre une
analyse en dix ans à cause des
abstentionnistes c'est à cause de
cahuzac et ça c'est vrai je pense qu'un
effet cahuzac très fort parce que en
moyenne dans les partiels
le ps perd moins 10 - 12 à peu près et
là il fait moins 24 donc voilà on peut
dire - 10.12 s'apprêter gouvernementale
- 10 - 12 qui a usé on se retrouve à
passer de 46 à à 23 ce qui est pas
glorieux ans je prends ça doit être une
des pires partiel que la vème république
et est connue donc que c'est la réalité
aux politiques